foreign
comes from Clinton in Texas should I
leave my 200 000 a year offshore
oilfield job at age 41 to live my dream
of being a charter boat captain in the
Caribbean I loathe my job by the way
that's a word that we should use more
loathe Loth is is a great substitute for
hate and it'll score you some points
just for quality work just that's a
little commercial I loathe my job and
even though I only started saving four
years ago thanks to Dave's videos I have
saved wait for it George just over 500
000 between retirement non-retirement
counts wow but I loathe my job two loads
he wins a prize yeah uh he says he's
currently living on his 38-foot sailboat
debt free and he's obtained his U.S
Coast Guard Master's license I'm eagerly
my job ahead South for the Caribbean
um I'm committed to putting 20 000 a
year in a universal life policy until
I'm 55. don't do that George will give
you more on that which I feel is an easy
task uh blah blah blah blah blah so
let's get to this
okay Clinton I think it's an easy answer
here Ken it's a very easy answer all
right it's time to get out the captain's
hat
it's time to put it on the head and it's
time to head down to the warm Waters and
Breeze of the Caribbean I love this dude
you've done the hard work you got 500
000 saved you're going to make really
good money you got no debt the only
issue I take with this entire thing is
the universal life policy agreed so
George while I'm picking out a captain's
hat for him in my mind and you know some
Tommy Bahama shirts I mean I'm I'm
picturing the whole thing Captain
Clinton oh what are you going to tell
him about the whole life yeah well he
said he's been watching Dave's videos
but he hasn't been watching closely
enough or watching them enough George is
no need to be snarky this let's just
come on Captain Clinton here out of all
the things in the financial world yeah
these Universal Life policies Whole Life
policies they drive me bonkers and
they're always pushed by Guess Who the
whole life sales people right and here's
what the problem with this in general
they go well Ken you could use your life
insurance policy as an investment
vehicle and make so much money tell me
more George well they take all of your
giant premiums they charge you they put
that in their pocket and then they give
you a crappy investment return
with these cash value parts of the
policy so here's what you do instead
instead of putting 20K a year in a
universal life policy get a term life
policy for 15 20 25 year term level term
and it's going to be a fraction of the
cost and with all the extra money you
just saved invest that money
and you'll be way better off don't
listen I don't know who sold you on this
man but you're a sharp guy and you don't
you do not need to be sinking nope no
pun intended there Ken I think you did
there 20K a year and I'd add one other
thing if I could Captain Clinton uh when
you get to the Caribbean email George
and I uh tell us where your charter boat
is with a photo give us a special
discount for our incredible advice that
we've given you and we'll do a camel
Coleman vacation we'll take the wives
down there and we'll get out there on
the boat with Captain Clinton Clinton
deserve it yeah a little catamaran maybe
you ever done one of those no it's
another great word nobody uses catamaran
gosh I tell you what George nobody
loathes being on a catamaran you listen
to this show and Ken will teach you
about 17 new 10 words that he's got in
his back pocket yeah you win at work Ken
is wealthy when it comes to vocabulary
didn't have a TV till I was 12. and it
shows read a lot of books and it shows
all right